you have all these propositions and et
cetera et cetera and they differ from
the religions and they're not
they don't seem to be considered
legitimate by many people
but yet there's something functioning in
the religions that is transforming
people
and making them wiser and i put it to
you
that the transformations are largely
occurring at those non-propositional
levels
the procedural the perspectival
and the participatory and those are the
ones by the way that are more
fundamentally connected to meaning
making because remember the propositions
are representational and they're
dependent on the non-propositional
non-representational processes of
connectedness and relevance realization
so religion goes down deep to the
non-propositional and works there that's
the functionality we need to grasp well
you talk about
tools essentially that humans are able
to incorporate into their cognition
psychotechnologies like language is one
i suppose
uh
isn't religion then
a psychotechnology it would be a yeah an
ecology of psychotechnologies yes and
the question is
that nietzsche ruined everything by
saying god is dead
uh do we have to invent the new thing go
go to from the old phone create the
iphone invent the new psychotechnology
that takes place of religion and so when
the madman in nietzsche's text goes into
the marketplace who's he talking to he's
not talking to the believers he's
talking to the atheists and he says do
you not realize what we have done
right we have taken a sponge and
wiped away the sky we are now forever
falling we are unchained from the sun we
have to become worthy of this
yeah well nietzsche is full of romantic
[ __ ] as well no no no but there's a
point there yes the point is
right there's one thing to rejecting the
proposition there's another project of
replacing the functionality that we lost
when we reject the religion so his worry
that is nihilism takes hold you don't
ever replace
the thing
that religion
uh
the role the religion played in our
maybe it's hard to tell what he actually
because he's so multi-vocal um i i i'll
speak for me rather than fenici i think
it is possible
to
using the best cognitive science and
respectfully accepting what we can from
the best religion
and philosophy philosophical traditions
because there's things like stoicism
that are in the gray line between
philosophy and religion
buddhism is the same
doing that best kagsai that best
exaptation we can come up with
that functionality without having to buy
into
the particular propositional sets of the
legacy religions that's my proposal i
call that the religion that's not a
religion so things like stoicism or
modern stoicism those things
don't you think in some sense they
naturally
emerge
don't you think there's a longing for
meaning
so stoicism arises during the
hellenistic period when there was a
significant meaning crisis in the
ancient world because of what had
happened after the breakup of alexander
the great's empire so
if you if you compare aristotle to
people who are living after
alexander so aristotle grows up in a
place where
everybody speaks the same has a language
has the same religion his ancestors have
been there for years he knows everybody
after alexander the great's empire
broken is broken up people are now
thousands of miles away from the
government
they're surrounded by people because of
the desporas right the
diasporas i should say they're
surrounded by people that don't speak
their language don't share their
religion that's why you get all these
mother religions emerging right
universal muslim religions like isis etc
so there is a there is what's called
domicide there's the killing of home
there's a loss of a sense of home and
belonging and fittedness during the
hellenistic period and stoicism
arose
specifically to address that and because
it was designed to address a meaning
crisis it is no coincidence that it is
coming back into prominence right now
well there there could be a lot of other
variations and it feels like it feels
like
i think when you speak of the meaning
crisis you're in part describing
not prescribing you're describing
something that is happening but
i would venture to say that
if we just leave things be
the the meaning crisis dissipates
because we long
to create institutions to create
collective ideas so this distributed
cognition process that give us meaning
so if religion loses power we'll find
other
institutions that are sources of meaning
i don't is that is that is that your
intuition as well
i think we are already doing that i do i
am involved with
and do participant observation
of many of these emerging communities
that are creating ecologies of practice
that are specifically about trying to
address the meeting crisis i just
in late july i went to washington state
and did rafe kelly's evolve move play
return to the source
and
one of the most challenging things i've
ever done
that guy is awesome by the way i've
gotten to interact with him a long long
time ago uh he said he said to say hi to
you by the way yeah it's from another
world it feels like a different world
uh because i interacted with him not
directly but so he this is somebody
maybe you can speak to what he works on
but
uh he makes movement and play
uh he encourages people to make that a
part of their life like how how you move
about the world whether that's as part
of sort of athletic endeavors or actual
just like walking around around the city
yeah um
and i think
the reason i ran into him is because
there was a lot of interest in that in
the athletic world in the in the
grappling world in the brazilian jiu
jitsu world
people who study movement who make
movement part of their life to see
how how can we integrate play and fun
and
and uh just the the basic humanness
that's natural
to our movement how do we integrate that
into our daily practice so
so this is yet another way to find
meaning i think it's actually an example
of what i was talking about because
what's going on with rafe's integration
of parkour in nature right and
martial arts
um and mindfulness practices and
dialogical practices
is exactly and explicitly so by the way
he's he will tell you he's been very
influenced by my work he's trying to get
at the non-propositional kinds of
knowing that make meaning by evolving
our sensory motor loop and enhancing our
relevance realization because that gives
people profound improved sense of
connectedness to themselves to each
other and the world and
i'll tell you alex i won't i don't want
to say the
i don't want to say too specifically the
final thing that people did because it's
part of his secret sauce right sure
right right but what i can say is when
it was done
i said to them all i said as far as i
can tell none of you are religious right
uh
yeah yeah but what you just did was a
religious act wasn't it and they all
went yeah it was
you